it rarely rains during the wheat growing
season at simmit research station near
oon in northwest Mexico and ironic as it
may seem that makes oon an excellent
site for testing rainfed wheat systems
researchers can precisely control water
through carefully managed irrigation
they can simulate everything from
extreme drought to Monsoon
rains for Yan Manis a rain-fed wheat
breeder at simmit this experiment to
compare wheat yields under zero tillage
with normally tilled wheat under
Precision water control was crying out
to be done there are three trials for
each treatment two of them are two
s so two semiarid will deal trials so
they are genotypes which are tested
internationally even when the wheat was
still a bit green and not quite ready
for Harvest he could see differences the
advantage here is that it's increasing
the chance to have the the remaining
speculates a bit of fi as expected wheat
under zero tillage appeared to do better
when subjected to water stress than the
same wheat grown on a ploud
field but the proof is in the grain
itself under water stress different
wheat lines may have different ways of
compensating only after harvesting the
grain using these miniature combine
Harvesters and a detailed analysis could
a result be determined of course the
zero tillage trial won at least under
the stress of less than Optimum
water